I think you mentioned like tank Davis
yeah before was not he said he wasn't a
pay-per-view draw but now after the
fight do you think that's changed a
little so I don't think he
I think the reason they did Big
pay-per-views obviously because Ryan
Garcia driven it was a big both semi big
names I think Ryan might have been a
little bit bigger of a name
um but yeah that fight might have put
him over the top to where he's like he
could be that guy boxing
um and I've been saying it for years I
would love to Connor fought Floyd I was
[__] all about it I watched every
time they did a press conference I was
all I loved it I loved how massive that
was and I've always wanted to be a part
of something like that and Miiverse
gervante if
I keep winning I'm the champ I gotta be
the champ potentially the double champ
and he's got to continue to win and be
undefeated and be great in his sport for
the next five years that's something a
potential massive super fight that I'll
be interested in yeah and you like that
one yeah
yeah I mean he's good he's [__]
really good I mean yeah buddy what the
[__] are you talking about what's going
on
were saying when I was 18 sandwich you
mean the UFC what are you [__] what
are you talking about yeah
so when I when people say that it
doesn't I'm like it doesn't it doesn't
really affect me it doesn't really I
like that do we make any bold statements
you've already said you're coming for
the belt next you already said you want
tank Davis eventually that could be a
really fun fight
boxing match and then well we know don't
say fight because why because you think
that you smoke them if it was well it
was the same argument with Connor Connor
Floyd say hey let's make sure we're
clarifying like there's rules so we're
boxing there's two a fight and it's not
even that's not entertainment that's
[__] bullying we're both
I mean if you guys are in MMA and you're
fighting against tank is it just kicking
it doesn't matter add any element in
there it's over fast really Jiu Jitsu
wrestling uh yeah kicks you have no
concern about getting caught
one of my most dangerous weapons are my
legs my kicks yeah there's no way he
could even hit me if we were kicking
like well he just doesn't know and
that's not because he sucks yeah well I
guess it is because he sucks but it's
not it's because he doesn't know yeah
you know he's a [__] good boxer and
it shows yeah the him versus Ryan Garcia
was very impressive that first round in
the clinch I was like Garcia's big and
he's bullying him he's gonna and [__]
sat down on that left hand and adjusted
he wasn't Landing those body shots early
on as he started you know creeping up a
little bit you know stepping a little
bit more forward he he the [__]
can box yeah he could be the face of
boxing that dude could you know go down
as one of the greatest of all times for
sure yeah and you think you have a
chance and I do true I mean hey I
wouldn't I would be calling it out if I
didn't think so I've had that you know
self belief in myself for for a long
time and a lot of people get very very
upset boxers especially when I call him
out but that only makes you more money
more money more it's just it's a big
[__] fight and a magic
I sleep that dude with boxing gloves on
sugar Ali baby